okay so I don't know who needs to know
this but taking photos of the moon on
the Samsung Galaxy s23 Ultra is kind of
actually ridiculous so that's that
folded Periscope Zoom at work that's
going to get you that hundred times
combined optical plus digital Zoom to
see yeah the details on the moon and
it's not one of those overlaid fake
things that Huawei has been accused of
in their phones in the past word on the
street is iPhone is possibly going to be
adding one of those folded Periscope
lenses in the next two to three years of
the iPhone but until then this is what
taking a photo of the Moon on the iPhone
14 pro looks like and this is what that
looks like on the Galaxy s23 Ultra be
sure to subscribe to see the full review
of this phone when it comes out because
there's a lot going on here